it turns out that there are US allies
that are investigating Donald Trump the
great Curt icon Walt from Newsweek who
we've had on the program before has
revealed some stunning new developments
about the Trump administration's dealing
with foreign leaders and how European
intelligence agencies are trying to
track it all and it turns out that as
part of intelligence operations against
the Trump staff at least one unnamed US
ally has intercepted a significant
amount of communication between Trump
staff and Russian government officials
now you might say well David you
reported this to us yesterday no what I
reported yesterday was that US
intelligence had based their conclusion
that the Trump team and Russia had been
in touch during the campaign based on
intercepted data they had obtained but
what I'm telling you now is that US
allies other countries have also
intercepted such information which has
led them to of course the same
conclusion and earlier this week of
course it was uncovered that national
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn made numerous phone calls to
Russia while President Obama was still
president to talk to them in in part
about sanctions but Michael Flynn denied
that they talked about sanctions Mike
Pence went out and said hey they didn't
talk about sanctions it turns out that
that was a lie but now other countries
US allies are also involved in the
obtaining and procuring of similar data
Newsweek sources who have direct
knowledge of the situation said that
these interceptions include at least one
correspondence between Flynn and an
official within the Russian embassy in
Washington DC again foreign agencies
foreign intelligence now corroborating
what American intelligence has come out
and said it's not clear if these
revelations refer to the phone calls
specifically to Russian ambassador
Sergei kiss lyac which led to Michael
Flynn's ultimate and eventual
resignation or if it's something new but
again the story is the same this other
country's intelligence agency is saying
that the interceptions are also not only
limited to phone calls we know that the
intelligence operations by American
allies began in August when Britain
again Britain is not necessarily the
country we're talking about but we know
that in August Britain did receive
intelligence that the Trump campaign was
communicating with Russia so now for all
of the trumpets who are falling in line
with Donald Trump's Proclamation that we
just can't trust our own intelligence
agencies we also now have foreign
intelligence agencies but not from rival
or antagonistic countries but from
American allies who are saying they have
figured out the exact same thing
multiple European NATO governments have
been conducting similar intelligence
operations related to Donald Trump and
communications with Russia there's also
an as-of-yet
unnamed Baltic country which has been
conducting intelligence operations
against the Trump Organization because
they're afraid is that a US Russia
friendship might threaten the
sovereignty of Baltic States so this is
not coming from some amorphous and vague
desire to hurt Trump or take him down at
least with regard to this Baltic state
they are seeing what seems like a
growing friendship between Donald Trump
and Vladimir Putin that is concerning to
them with regard to their own national
security of course Newsweek sources
cited by Kurt Icahn walled in the
article I'm referencing here spoke on
the condition of anonymity because
obviously they don't have the authority
to disclose any of this information and
they are worried that Donald Trump and
his team which are have been
demonstrated time and again to be
incredibly unstable might try to
retaliate against their governments and
one of the sources says that this
intelligence is being spread all around
NATO intelligence agencies
clear how much of it is being shared
with American intelligence agencies
think about what's going on Pat we now
have learned number one Donald Trump is
aggressively attacking the credibility
of American intelligence agencies I
think that that's risky I'm going to
talk about that later we've also learned
that American intelligence agencies
because they are aware or at least
fearful of how much of an open door
there is between the Trump White House
and Russia they are withholding
information from Donald Trump and we've
now learned that foreign intelligence
agencies from allies of the u.s. are
withholding information from American
intelligence again because they are
worried about how much is in their
interest to reveal this is a you
mentioned yesterday I think it was going
back to j edgar Hoover this sort of
level of disconnect or distress between
the White House and intelligence
agencies we have a stunning situation
here don't we well I think it's great
that foreign governments are looking
into this because maybe our own
intelligence agencies could be more
tentative or reserved about criticizing
the Trump administration especially when
their jobs could be at stake but with
regards to foreign governments I mean
they don't have as big of a dog in the
fight I mean Trump could threaten
certain things like pulling out of NATO
for example or starting some sort of
trade war but I think the risk is far
lower with them well on the one hand we
have European nations that seem to know
more about what's going on in the White
House then certain American branches of
government do who bizarrely maybe not
bizarrely but distressingly seem
unwilling to look into Donald Trump's
ties with Russia Congress has rejected
the probing of Donald Trump's
relationships and business partnerships
with other countries or the Trump staffs
relationship with Russia etc and in
addition to this you have what I think
you're right in terms of some of these
countries don't necessarily have a dog
in the fight in terms of Trump versus
Clinton or whatever sort of micro thing
we have going on but the Baltic state
example is a good one which is some of
these countries might see what seems to
be a very very increasingly clear
friendship between the white house and
the crowd
that is concerning to them with regard
to sort of their own national security
and their own place within the
geopolitical world Republicans need to
stop the political defensiveness and
start looking into what is going on here
they are defending a guy because he has
an R in front of his name at the risk of
ignoring potential a serious corruption
here we seem to be sort of living in a
movie and in fact if this were a
Hollywood script I almost feel like we
would see it and say we've got to tone
it down because this just isn't
believable it's actually 2017 American
politics and it's going on if we're
going to continue covering it